as one of the pioneers in solar energy
here in vegas solar wants to help you
save the environment and save some money
here's how
[Music]
here in nevada and las vegas why
shouldn't you have solar it's it's
it makes all the sense in the world it
makes sense financially because we have
so much sunshine
we have 360 days of sunshine every year
so solar pays for itself you don't even
need to call it an investment
because what you pay for solo you get
paid back by having lower
or no power bills regularly every month
so we were doing mostly residential
solar projects a few commercial
projects so meaning we put solar on
residential homes
we sell the systems we engineer the
system so we have an
in-house engineering team which pretty
much no one else does
so we have our own installation crew
which is a crucial element of a solar
company today
if you look around with all these
companies you have in town right now i
believe it's
up to i don't know even 90 companies
right now
almost none of them have their
installation team so they're basically
nothing else than
a sales office selling a solar system
and then
bring it to some contractor to install
the system
so we do everything in-house everything
connected and obviously this is really
the way to do it
to get the best quality in all stages of
the project
well let's face it uh solar is a
significant amount of money you have to
spend so it's all about trust
and so the solar industry is fairly
unique in the world
where else do you have warranties that
cover like 25 years
just imagine you would have a car with a
25 year warranty
so this makes it really really unique
but the warranties are not worth the
paper if you cannot trust
the company the suppliers that are
behind these warranties
and that's why it's important that we've
been here on the market for more than 10
years
and probably stay here for more than 10
years compared to a lot of other
companies that
just went out of business after just a
few months of business on operations
[Music]
the night outside is our newest employee
so
he is there to demonstrate what seoul is
all about
it's about protection protecting
the safety of our customers having power
even in the worst periods
but it's also about protecting
investment so we don't know what energy
prices are going to do
in the future and with the solar system
you are protected it's like a home
insurance on energy rates
people see us from the streets and we
want to give clients the feeling
that they can trust that if there is any
issue
they're not talking to a person maybe
sitting in
india or the philippines
so if you have an issue with us just
come on in
the doors are open you can even talk to
me
call seoul up at 702-586-9800 or just
head to seoulup.com and fyi
they guarantee installation or soul up
will pay the difference
in tax credits so there's more las vegas
now just ahead in less than three
minutes
so go